economía en directo américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio mejores
portadores que vamos a hablar del banco
central europeo que puso fin a una
década de política monetaria en la zona
euro porque jorge anuncia el final
también de las compras de deudas y de
los tipos negativos para hacer frente a
la inflación el banco central europeo
reunido en abstener anunció que la
compra de deuda terminará el primero de
julio y será ese mismo mes cuando
producirá se produciría la primera
subida de tipos del 0.25 por ciento
aunque dijeron que no será la única el
banco central dejó entrever la
posibilidad de realizar un aumento más
drástico de medio punto porcentual en
septiembre en lugar del ajuste más
habitual de un cuarto de punto la subida
de los tipos de interés era inevitable
el resto de bancos centrales del mundo
lo están haciendo para controlar la
inflación que en europa alcanzó el 8,1
por ciento interanual en mayo es la más
alta desde que existe el euro y es
cuatro veces superior al objetivo del 2%
que se había fijado el banco central
para este año el banco también redujo su
previsión de crecimiento para este año
del 37 % y lo ubicó al 2,8 también
aumentó su previsión de inflación para
el 2022 el 68
en el 2023 al 35 y en el 2024 al 21 por
ciento nos vamos hasta china que brindó
los datos de su comercio jorge los
intercambios comerciales de china con el
resto del mundo crecieron en mayo un 96
por ciento en términos interanuales esto
luego del frenazo de abril cuando
avanzaron un 0,1 por ciento por los
confinamientos del cob y 19 según datos
de la administración general de aduanas
en el quinto mes del año los
intercambios con otros países alcanzaron
los 515 mil ochocientos sesenta millones
de dólares el crecimiento de las
exportaciones del país asiático aumentó
un 15 3 por ciento en valor con respecto
a mayo del año pasado mientras las
importaciones fueron a un ritmo mucho
menor el 28 por ciento y alcanzaron 220
mil 80 millones de dólares y vamos con
una noticia que estábamos adelantando en
este informativo tailandia probó la
legalización del cultivo y la posición
de marihuana a partir de este jueves
bueno los tailandeses lo celebraron
comprando marihuana en una cafetería que
hasta ahora se limitaba a vender
productos derivados de la planta las
autoridades no han en ningún esfuerzo
por vigilar lo que la gente puede
cultivar y fumar en sus casas aunque
algo en tailandés dijo que los
consumidores con fines recreativos que
fuman en público podrían enfrentarse a
sanciones como cárcel por tres meses y
una multa de 780 dólares el país apuesta
por el potencial económico en el mercado
de la marihuana medicinal la nueva
legislación comenzó a llamar la atención
de inversionistas privados la noticia no
solo fue celebrada por los consumidores
raúl al menos 4.000 personas que habían
sido encarceladas por delitos
relacionados con el cannabis saldrán en
libertad las mejores vamos ahora a
francia porque disney se opuso en la
nueva cronología de los medios franceses
de hecho disney no estrenará su película
stranger en francia y la estrenará
solamente en disney plus la cronología
de medios es una normativa del gobierno
francés que determina el tiempo que debe
transcurrir antes de que una película
estrenada en las salas de cines pueda
estar disponible en el streaming la
cronología en cuanto a las reglas de
exhibición es de 45 y entre los estrenos
de salas y las transmisiones en línea
pero en francia esa brecha es mucho más
larga son 17 meses la ley busca proteger
a la industria cinematográfica del país
de las superproducciones de hollywood
que abundan sobre todo en la oferta
streaming
que esta nueva cronología es anti
consumidor e ignora cómo ha evolucionado
el comportamiento de los últimos años de
los consumidores y que seguirán tomando
decisiones película por película la
federación nacional de cine francés
reaccionó al anuncio de disney diciendo
que socavaría gravemente la economía de
los cines y del sector en su conjunto la
disputa se da cuando las salas de cine
luchan por recuperar los niveles de
asistencia previo a la pandemia y temen
que la medida de disney la secunden
otras productoras esto según ellos
representaría una pérdida de taquilla de
20 millones de euros anuales netflix
aceptó el acuerdo con francia pero
amazon aún no se ha pronunciado al
respecto y nos venimos a nuestra región
porque argentina cumplió con las metas
del fm y pasó la primera revisión del
acuerdo del préstamo bueno el organismo
y las autoridades argentinas llegaron a
un acuerdo a nivel de personal técnico
sobre la primera revisión esto
permitiría a argentina tener acceso a
unos 4 mil 30 millones de dólares así lo
señaló la directora adjunta del
departamento del hemisferio occidental
julie kozack quien agregó que el visto
bueno por parte del directorio ejecutivo
del fmi sede en las próximas semanas
según ella se cumplieron todas las metas
cuantitativas en el primer trimestre de
2022 y que se están logrando también
avances en esta agenda en marzo
argentina firmó un programa de
facilidades extendidas con el fm para
financiar una deuda por 44 mil millones
de dólares que fue derivada de un
acuerdo previo que se firmó en el 2018
durante el gobierno de mauricio macri
jóvenes muchisimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica nos
vemos más adelante con más nos vamos
directo hasta los ángeles